がちゃがちゃがやりたくて
amazonで探してたんですよ
がちゃがちゃの本体がほしいなと思って
amazonで探してたら
6000円くらいであったんですよ！
6000円くらいでがちゃがちゃの本体が売ってて
それでなんか怪しいなーと思ったんですよ
6000円でがちゃがちゃの本体買えるんですよ
怪しいと思っていろいろ調べたら
ちゃんと｢公式のがちゃがちゃです｣って書いてあって
やばい！買える！！と思って
買って届きました
6000円で家でがちゃがちゃできるのか！と思って
買ったんですけど
（段ボール開封）
・・・・・・。
小さいねぇ(おこ)
小さぁぁぁあ”いっ!!!(激おこ)
約1/2サイズって書いてある偽物だよぉぉお”お”!!(激おこぷんぷん丸)
完全偽物だよぉお!!(おこ)
ｲｷｵｲｱﾏｯﾃ2ｺｶｯﾁｬｯﾀﾖ(なぜかカタコト)
なんかぁ、ほら、あれじゃんね
なんか
おもちゃ用、おもちゃじゃん！おもちゃ！
うわ小さっ！
おもちゃだよこれはぁっ!!(激おこ)
(ﾄﾞﾝｯｯ)
ただのおもちゃだよぉぉお”お”お”っ!!!(ﾑｶ着火ﾌｧｲﾔｰ!!!)
(ﾄﾞｽﾝｯｯｯ)
というわけで･･･
ちゃんと本物を見つけてきました!!
いざっ!!!
KA☆I☆FU☆U☆!!!
＞＞＞＞＞＞＞＞＞＞開封の儀＜＜＜＜＜＜＜＜＜＜
あーちょっと待ってちょっと待って
怖いなあ･･･
ちょっと怖いなぁ
がちゃがちゃ本体傷ついたらすごい怖
わ”あぁぁぁぁぁ”ぁ”ぁ"あ”あ”い”っ
＞＞＞＞＞＞＞＞開封の儀再開☆＜＜＜＜＜＜＜＜
えーこれで中身壊れてたら俺もうやだぁ
(いざ、開封)
(いざ、雑に開封)
うわぁぁぁっ
(本体召喚)
これですよぉぉっ!!!
これを待ってたんすよぉっ!!!
暑い
うぉーうぉーうぉーうおー!
うぉー×5
わーーーっ!
これだよこれこれこれ!!!
ほっほｗすごいすごいｗｗｗ
本物だぁっ!!!(少年並みのｷﾗｷﾗ感)
うわすごいっ!!!
えまって、ほんとじゃん!!
やったーーーーーーーっ!!
はいというわけでようやく念願に
手に入れることができました
がちゃがちゃでございます(泣)
ほんとねぇ
がちゃがちゃは欲しかった
これが家にあるってもう、んもぉ
男のロマンですからね!!!
いや、めっちゃがちゃがちゃ好きだから
これを実際に家においておきたかった仮説はある(?)
(ｶﾞﾁｬｶﾞﾁｬｶﾞﾁｬｶﾞﾁｬ)
うわぁっ(楽しそう)
売り切れっ☆(嬉しそうｗ)
ここで100円玉何枚入れたら回せるかっていうのが
わかるみたいっすねぇっ!!!
これなんか･･･
(ﾍﾞﾘｯ)
あぁーー
えっ、なにこれ
うりきれが落ちてきちゃった
これでこの中に物を入れるんですねぇ
すげーなぁ!!!
なぜそもそも僕がちゃがちゃなんて買ったかっていいますと
自分でがちゃがちゃを作りたかった･･･っ!
よくいろんながちゃがちゃあるじゃないですかなんか
何が出るかわからないガチャとか
千円ガチャとか
ああいうがちゃがちゃって
もうだいたい出るのがもうある程度決まってるんですよ
なんかよくわかんない腕輪とか
なんでこんなの売ってんのみたいな靴紐とか
あんまり売れなかったがちゃがちゃの残りとか
もうだいだいねぇああいうなんか
何出るかわかんないがちゃがちゃって
出るのがだいたい決まってると思うんですよ
だいたい把握ができる!!!!
そんなんじゃまだまだ甘いｯｯｯ!!!!!
俺は!俺だけの！
俺のオリジナリティー溢れる！
自分だけのがちゃがちゃマシンが作りたいと思ったので
がちゃがちゃを購入しました
まってでもカプセル無くね？
いやまってカプセル買ったぞ!!!?
なんか一応カプセル自分で買ってたみたいです･･･www
こういう時だけ準備いいんすよねｗ
あーーーー！
これ1回ちゃんとできるかやってみましょう
ほんとに出るかどうか確かめないと
いきます
(ｶﾞﾁｬｶﾞﾁｬ)
(ｺﾛﾝｯ)
できた×3!!!
ここから中身に僕が物を決めて入れて
もうほんとに私が自分で作ったがちゃがちゃを今日は
皆さんに披露したいと思います
いくぜっ☆
はいっ、というわけで僕のがちゃがちゃ
完成しました
中に入っている物はもちろん
他のがちゃがちゃでは見られないレア物ばかり･･･
1回100円だと手に入らないような物を入れてみたんですけど藻
これからちょっとね色んなお客さんが僕ん家に来るんで
まあちょっとみんなにがちゃがちゃをやってもらって
ハッピーな気持ちになってもらいたいなと思います
ではいこう
(ｶﾞﾁｬｯｯ)
(1人目：まさき)
ま）1回100円？
(ｶﾞﾁｬｶﾞﾁｬｯ)
ま）ﾌｯｯwwww
ま）ﾌｯﾌｯｯwww
ま）マッチ？？ｗｗ
(2回目)
(ｶﾞﾁｬｶﾞﾁｬｯ)
ま）ﾌﾌﾌﾌｯｯwwww
ま）なんで？ｗｗ
ま）なんで？ｗ
ま）ポケモンGOのやつでしょ？
ま）えっ？なになになになに？ｗ
（2人目：トロール☆）
ト）んっふっふｗｗｗ
ト)はじめくーん
ト）はじめくーん？
ト）えっこれなに？
ト）まわっ、え、お金入れなきゃだめでしょこれ
ト）え、お金入れんの？これ
ト）え、お金入れるの？
ト）え、お金入れなきゃだめなやつ？これ
ト）ほんとにまわ、回るの？これ
(ｶﾞﾁｬｶﾞﾁｬｯ)
ト）おっ
ト）はっ？何これ
ト）ぐっｗふふっｗはっ？ｗ
ト）おじゃましまーす
ト）はじめくーん？
ト）どうしたの？
ト）へっ？
ト）え、特にこれといって･･･
ト）変わったあれ･･･
ト）んん～ちゃんと普通の歯磨き粉だねぇ･･･
(ｶﾞﾁｬｶﾞﾁｬｯ)
ト）BB弾～(ドラ○もん風)
ト）BB弾～･･･
は）落ちてこなかったですか･･･？
ト）うん、落ちてこないよ
は）勢いよく開けてくださいここで
ト）いや1回これｗｗｗ
は）1回勢いよく開けてくださいｗ
ト）なにかな～
ト）なんか、すごいシャリシャリしてるなんか･･･
ト）ミントガムかな？
ト）ミントガムかなんか･･･
ト）やっぱりこうほら
ト）今ユーチューｂ
(早送り☆)
ト）やばそうだねっ!!!
ト）うわっ
(こぼれ落ちるBB弾たち)
ト）・・・・・・・。
ト）んっ？
ト）BB弾が散ったねぇｗ
♪エンディング♪